[Music]
the avengers are an eclectic group of uh
famous superheroes there's the hulk
there's iron man there's thor you got a
lot of great people in the event yeah a
lot of classic comic heroes but even so
not every superhero is chosen to be in
the avengers
here are some of them now
in a little piece we're calling rejected
avengers
[Applause]
car here we go first up uh people love
the superhero captain america but
they're less excited about this overly
specific hero captain america ferrara
i will not rest
until abc brings back ugly betty
[Music]
few superheroes are more intimidating
than the ghost rider a biker from hell
with a flaming skull head which is
probably why the avengers rejected the
far less intimidating ghost rider on an
old-timey bicycle
[Applause]
[Music]
i love that oh we're showing him get off
that's terrific
[Laughter]
well important to capture that moment
well i better get down now
our next rejected adventure has the
superhuman strength of iron man but he
was rejected from the avengers because
of his crippling iron deficiency please
welcome iron deficiency man
[Applause]
[Music]
is anyone can get the flaming skull to
ride through one more time can we get
that to happen
is that possible they can't do yeah
let's see if they can do it well that'll
come up later i just gotta i gotta see
that happened
[Applause]
and now my favorite part him getting off
you try and make that curve
that turn in an old-timey bike yeah
uh this next guy this next hero should
be the most brutal and feared of all the
superheroes but he was cut from the
avengers because of his stringent fad
diet that's right it's the incredible 36
day juice fast hulk
oh yeah
whoa
puck feel great
[Music]
i don't think they put green on his
armpit
can you check the still there
check the still when you get a chance
there alan i think they neglected to put
green
armpit
just making sure right that we don't get
fan corrections for this look at asa
yeah
all right our next rejected avenger may
or may not
be celebrity chef gordon ramsay
he's too fast for us to actually tell
it's flash gordon ramsay
[Music]
i don't need to see that again
i can't believe gordon ramsay did that i
know wow i didn't hear him swearing
though
finally our last rejected avenger is a
close relative of the super stretchy mr
fantastic from the fantastic four now
unfortunately she's lost some of her
elasticity with age that's right it's mr
fantastic's grandmother
[Applause]
[Music]
there they are ladies and gentlemen the
rejected avengers
one more time
go for it
one more time
yeah
[Applause]
and
get off
you